for centuries scientists and especially
physicists have believed that we would
be able to show why our universe is as
it is as a necessary consequence of
certain fundamental principles and laws
like finding having crossword puzzle
with only one solution that given
certain very fundamental principles like
the law of conservation of energy that
there would be only one self-consistent
universe allowed and that has been sort
of the holy grail of physics and we have
been pretty successful and showing such
things as why snowflakes have six-sided
symmetry why raindrops are round why the
sky is blue and as necessary
consequences of a small number of
physical principles what has happened in
the last 10 years or so or 15 years as
we now believe when I say we I mean most
theoretical physicists now believe that
our universe is just one of a vast
number of universes all with very
different physical properties and all of
these different universes originate from
the same fundamental principles so
there's not one solution to the
crossword puzzle there are many
solutions to the crossword puzzles in
that case there's no possibility of
explaining why our universe is a
necessary consequence of the fundamental
principles there are many many different
possibilities some of these other
universes might have 17 dimensions some
of them might have planets and stars
like ours others may
have just a an amorphous field of energy
with no planets and stars
some of them might allow life like our
universe some of them may not allow life
and our universe is just one lucky draw
from the Hat
in which case we are accidental we are
an accidental universe and so the
historic mission of of science and
especially physics to show that that we
are our universes is the unique result
of a certain set of fundamental
principles that historic mission is no
longer feasible it's no longer possible
this conclusion makes theoretical
physicists extremely unhappy because it
means that a lot of our mission is an
illusion but that may be the way nature
is